sheriff we've all been wondering about
officer chamois Colonus he was shot a
couple weeks ago now during a protest
how is he doing well I appreciate you
asking Alex unfortunately not well there
hasn't been significant change since the
last reporting of his condition and
under permission of the family through a
Twitter feed they announced to the
public that he has paralysis and it's
probably going to be for the rest of his
life and then who will probably require
a respirator for the rest of his life so
but he is alert he's he's opened his
eyes he appears to show some awareness
of his family members so that is a
bright light in his condition currently
we're attempting to get into an extended
Rehab senator and dipper Colorado he is
dealing with a current issue so he's
unable to be transported as we speak but
with fingers crossed and prayers given I
anticipate you'll be able to move to a
better facility to ensure his long-term
care well we are all wishing the very
best for him off for officer Michael
owners and his family so sheriff
Lombardo thank you so much for being
with us and for all you do we appreciate
it